[Música]
Olá,
minhas amigas, meus amigos. Sejam
bem-vindos para mais uma live. É um
prazer estar aqui com vocês.
Deixa eu mudar aqui a
apresentação que não era essa.
Ah, gozado. Não era
bem. Vamos lá.
Hã,
isso, isso que eu queria fazer, não que
eu queria já mostrar a tela para vocês.
Não sei porque que tá hoje. Tá diferente
isso aqui.
Pera aí.
Era
para tá mais à direita essa imagem aqui.
Não sei porque que tá para cá.
Estranho. Ah, agora sim. Pronto.
Boa noite, Enilde. Boa noite, Antônio
Renato. Por favor, vamos me dizendo se o
áudio tá bom paraa gente poder continuar
aqui.
Bem, hoje tem bastante pergunta, tem
umas 20 perguntas, então acho que não
vai dar tempo da gente discutir nenhum
artigo, não.
Bem, enquanto vocês vão me dando o
feedback, se vocês estão me escutando
bem, eu vou continuar aqui, tá?
Deixa eu dividir a tela com vocês.
Deixa eu aumentar o tamanho.
Ah, obrigado, Reginaldo. Áudio. OK.
Legal.
Primeira pergunta. Está valendo a bula
da ciprofloxacino e tem bastante
possíveis efeitos colaterais.
Teria algo para fazer que diminuísse ou
prevenisse os efeitos?
Bem, o cipro ou ciprofloxacina é um
antibiótico que tem uma potência
geralmente adequada,
mas tem vários efeitos colaterais
possíveis, náuseas, vômitos, diarreia,
dor de cabeça, alterações de sistema
nervoso, isso é como mais endosos,
tendinite, arritmia cardíaca
e não tem uma medida universal que possa
ser instituída para prevenir
completamente esses efeitos colaterais.
Mas existem algumas estratégias que você
pode implementar para minimizar os
riscos e aumentar a tolerabilidade.
Então, primeiro é seguir corretamente o
uso.
Não altere a dose, nem tome tudo de uma
vez e nem estenda o tratamento além do
recomendado.
Evitar automedicação importante para
evitar resistência bacteriana.
Existe alguns alimentos que podem piorar
os efeitos colaterais, por exemplo,
durante o tratamento, evite leite,
iogurte ou sucos enriquecidos com
cálcio,
porque o cálcio no leite e nesses outros
produtos pode reduzir a absorção da
ciprofluxacino.
Tem que tomar cuidado com interações
medicamentosas também.
Ainda bem que são medicamentos menos
utilizados, mais raros, mas, por
exemplo, teofilina pode interagir,
tanidina pode interagir e proencida
também, né? Isso aumenta o risco de
efeitos colaterais. também evitar o uso
com antiácidos e suplementos minerais
que podem interferir na absorção também
por causa da questão do cálcio.
Então, se a pessoa faz atividade física
intensa, ela deve reduzir durante o uso
do antibiótico por causa do risco de
tendinite, né? Então isso vai ser mais
comum idosos que estão fazendo
atividades físicas intensas ou pessoas
que estão utilizando corticoides.
Então é bom evitar os exercícios
intensos que podem sobrecarregar tendão,
especialmente o tendão de aquiles.
Pessoas que já t problema nervoso
central, por exemplo, pessoas que tm
demência ou
Parkinson, já deve evitar também o
ciprofloxacino, porque pode acontecer
convulsões, alucinações, agitação
em pessoas já têm propensão a doença do
nervoso central.
Pessoas estão tomando circo também deve
evitar a exposição excessiva ao sol,
porque o cplofloxacino pode aumentar a
sensibilidade à luz ultravioleta.
Manter-se hidratado é muito bom. Isso
ajuda a proteger os rins
e também se mantendo hidratado você vai
evitar retinas cardíacas.
Pessoas que têm histórico de doenças
cardíacas tem que tomar um especial
cuidado também com o ciprofloxacino
e tem que fazer um monitoramento
cardíaco adequado, tá bom? Então, seria
esse os cuidados principais. Vamos pra
próxima pergunta.
Qual é o melhor colágeno para idosos com
osteoporose?
Tem basicamente no mercado o colágeno
tipo um e o tipo dois, tá? O tipo um ele
é mais indicado paraa saúde dos ossos,
que ele também é um componente
importante da matriz óssea.
O tipo um hidrolizado em peptídeos, ele
é recomendado porque ele aumenta a
absorção. O tipo dois é mais recomendado
pra saúde das articulações.
Então, dores articulares, geralmente
você vai usar o tipo dois.
E o tipo um que eu não comentei também
seria o mais indicado também para pele e
para músculos e para saúde intestinal.
Então para idosa é melhor utilizar
sempre a fal hidrolizada, né? que vai
aumentar a absorção.
E é interessante você associar o
colágeno a outros nutrientes, como é
caso da vitamina D, do cálcio, da
vitamina K2, que vão ajudar mais ainda
na questão do osso e também o magnésio.
O colágeno verissol é um colágeno que eu
passo muito pra pele, para músculo e
para intestino, tá?
Ele também tá indicado para cabelos e
unhas. Então, se esse for objetivo, ele
é um bom produto.
Vamos para a próxima pergunta.
Família deseja saber se tem algum
inconveniente usar palmito etanolamina,
que é o pea. Eu já falei do pe aqui em
lives anteriores e eu já falei também em
vídeos no canal. Pé é muito bom. Eu uso
hoje bastante no consultório.
Ele é um composto natural. Ele pertence
à família das amidas, de ácidos grassos.
Ele vai atuar no sistema
endocanabinoide. Então ele é muito bom
como antiinflamatório.
Ele tá presente em ovos, em amendoim.
Ele tem ação defamatória analgésica.
É muito bom para dor crônica, para
inflamação, dor neuropática, artrite,
fibromialgia,
dor de ciático, dores musculares,
articulares.
E para quem tá tomando cannabis deol ou
extrato de cannabis, ele vai ser um
excelente parceiro, como eu falei,
porque ele atua nos receptores do
sistema endocanabinoide, tanto no CB1
quanto no CB2, quanto nos receptores
vaniloides,
tá? Então ele vai modular a resposta
inflamatória,
a percepção da dor.
Estudos clínicos e metanálise mostraram
que ele pode reduzir de forma
significativa a intensidade da dor e
melhorar a qualidade de vida de
pacientes que têm dor crônica.
Ele tem um perfil de segurança muito
bom, ele é muito tranquilo de usar,
inclusive tem metaanálises aí com
centenas de pacientes usando doses bem
altas de até
100 mg sem nenhum problema de efeitos
adversos importantes.
E toxicidade grave praticamente zero.
Como é uma substância que faz parte do
próprio organismo, isso aumenta até essa
questão da
segurança,
pode ser utilizado por qualquer adulto,
pode ser associado à curcumina, bozoia,
a cannabis,
a várias outras substâncias para
aumentar o efeito antiinflamatório. MSM
também uma boa, né? Quando é dor
articular,
a dose habitual é de 300 a 600 mg dia,
mas é comum chegar até 10000 sem maiores
problemas.
OK?
Próxima pergunta.
Uma pessoa que toma os 15 minutos de sol
antes das 9 horas da manhã e logo depois
toma banho, o banho retira o efeito do
sol? Não, não tira.
Essa história de tomar banho depois de
tomar sol, foi o Lair Ribeiro que
divulgou isso, mas ele tava falando da
vitamina D, que é produzido pela pele,
tá? Não tem nada a ver com os outros
efeitos positivos do sol, não.
A vitamina D é produzida na pele nas
camadas mais profundas, onde os raios
ultravioleta B atuam e não é na
superfície.
Então, o Dr. Ribeiro falava para esperar
40 minutos entre você fazer a exposição
solar e tomar o banho, mas eu acredito
que isso não vai fazer muita diferença,
porque tomar o banho não vai lavar ou
eliminar a vitamina D pele.
Nós sabemos que a exposição solar é
muito mais do que só a vitamina D. Ela
ajuda a regular o ritmo cicadiano, entre
várias outras coisas, e também vai
ajudar a regular melatonina
durante o ciclo sono vigília.
Então, tomar o banho após o sol não vai
afetar a regulação hormonal, nem o
efeito benéfico da luz solar, ok? Então,
não se preocupe com isso.
Pera aí, a pergunta individual.
Quais são os perigos do azeite de oliva
falsificado paraa saúde?
Sendo que as marcas boas custam caro,
uma pessoa é tentada comprar macas
baratas. É melhor não tomar nada do que
tomar maca barata. Essa que é a verdade.
Aqui na minha casa já tomamos as de
oliva Verdade do Esporão, que é marca
boa. E os meus pais também tomam, né?
Notamos que a marca mais barata tem um
gosto mais fraco. O que isso significa?
O fato desse azeite ser fraco significa
pirataria.
Bem, o que acontece muito no Brasil que
existe muita picaretagem nos rótulos,
né? Então eles colocam os nomes
genéricos assim, tipo
azeite tipo único, que é misturado com
óleo de soja e outras
malabarismos de palavras assim de
termos, né?
Então é muito comum a falsificação do
azeite, a mistura dele com óleos
vegetais mais baratos, seja soja,
gerassol, canola.
Tem casos de fraudes mais graves que são
utilizados solventes, corantes ou
aromatizantes não autorizados.
Então, tomar muito cuidado com isso.
Além de você não tá ingerindo um produto
de boa qualidade, você pode ter
problemas gastrointestinais, dor
abdominal, diarreia, náusea, vômitos.
Em casos extremos até intoxicações
importantes com risco de morte, tá? Isso
aí bem mais ro, obviamente, mas existe
o azeite de oliva puro, né? O que seja
virgem ou extravirgem de baixa acidez,
ele é muito rico em polifenóis.
Ele vai te dar proteção cardiovascular
cerebral e reduzir processos
inflamatórios.
Obviamente um bom azeite vai ser caro
por questões de ser pressado a frio e
isso é um processo mais caro e que que
você vai precisar de mais olivas para
produzir a mesma quantidade de óleo.
O sabor e o aroma do azeite de oliva
extra virgem é bem marcante. Geralmente
ele tem sabor frutado e lev levemente
amargo que lembra a azeitona. E quando o
azeite tem sabor e aroma fraco, neutro
ou lembrando óleos e cozinha, isso pode
indicar adteração ou baixa pureza.
Então tem que ficar atento quant isso
sim. Isso é um indício de produto ruim.
Geralmente os azeites adulterados também
tm a cor mais clara, tem menos
viscosidade
e não congelam da mesma maneira que o
azeite puro quando submetido a baixas
temperaturas.
Então o azeite barato,
ele tem sabor mais fraco. Isso é sim um
forte indicativo de adulteração.
Então como se proteger? Desconfio de
preços muito baixos.
Prefire marcas
reconhecidas e auditadas.
Leia atentamente ao rótulo. Isso é o
mais importante, porque tem muita
picaretagem no rótulo, tem muita
pegadinha no rótulo.
Muito cuidado com isso.
Observe o aroma e sabor, como você mesmo
pontuou aí, né? O cheiro e gosto
marcantes da azeitona são importantes.
Evite produtos que têm esse gosto que
lembre soja ou que tem um cheiro fraco
e de preferência para embalagem de vidro
escuro. Isso protege contra a oxidação
pela luz. Beleza?
Então fique atento e tome cuidado. Nem
sempre a marca também. Às vezes a mesma
marca tem produtos de qualidades
diferentes, né? Às vezes eles fazem esse
truque aí. Eles pegam um nome
consolidado e vende o produto mais
barato
eh para poder ter uma margem de lucro
mais alta no produto de baixa qualidade.
Então, tomar cuidado com isso.
Vi em grupos do Reddit de autistas que
uma pessoa reclamou que a versão, a
palavra cura,
segundo ele, pelo que li de outros
autistas, parece que eles estão querendo
até negar o autismo,
que seja uma doença que precise ser
curada. Gente, você tem que entender
como é que funciona a cabeça de um pai e
de uma mãe com autismo. Eu tenho um
filho autista, então eu posso falar com
direito, né,
de palavra sobre esse assunto. Além de
ser pai de autista e também de ser
médico. As pessoas elas buscam
desesperadamente uma saída, então elas
começam a fantasiar um monte de coisa.
Então, começam a achar que crianças
autistas todas são iguais no sentido de
serem
ã de performance muito acima da média,
começam a fantasiar que não é doença,
começam a fantasiar
que, enfim,
são pessoas diferentes. É são um
mecanismo de defesa que a pessoa
desenvolve para lidar com uma coisa tão
dolorosa quanto ter esse diagnóstico.
Então a gente tem que ter muito carinho,
muito amor e muita compreensão esses
casos, tá?
Eh, eles se conformam como uma espécie
de escape. Concordo com isso. Forçar até
spique autismo. Não entendi isso aqui.
Uma fundação que pesquisava a cura,
retirar a palavra cura de suas
pesquisas. É, é, é, é a questão das
pessoas hoje não ter resiliência, não
ter, eh, enfim, capacidade de aguentar
um diagnóstico tão pesado, né? Você,
como médico integrativo, acha que essa
postura dos autistas
e Benfica ou a longo prazo pode
prejudicar as curias? Pessoal, vamos
tomar um cuidado na hora de escrever as
perguntas, né? um pouquinho mais de
cuidado, joga no chat PT para melhorar a
pergunta, né? Eh, porque às vezes fica
até difícil de entender o que você
estavam querendo dizer aqui.
Então, vamos lá. Já falei um pouco sobre
isso, né?
A palavra cura nesses casos virou
realmente um
tabu, né?
A gente tem que tomar muito cuidado com
as sensibilidades individuais das
pessoas, né?
Então tem essa hoje essa ideia que dos
pais de autista, de parentes de autista,
que o autismo não é doença, que na
verdade seria uma identidade.
Isso também não podemos negar que vem do
movimento walk, né? que como hoje
quer normalizar várias coisas que
a gente entende como uma alteração de
saúde, por exemplo, obesidade. Eles
estão querendo dizer que não é mais uma
doença, que é um estilo de vida, que é
uma escolha, que é um que é uma
diversidade. Vocês estão entendendo o
que eu tô querendo dizer aqui, né?
Então, a gente tem que respeitar as
pessoas, né, os pontos de vista
diferentes, mas
hã
essa situação que eles estão colocando,
né, que seria uma variação da
normalidade, que seria uma uma
característica, não um defeito, é uma
defesa. Como eu falei,
para eles falar em curar o autismo seria
negar a identidade e valorizar apenas o
aspecto do padrão neurotípico.
Então, o uso termo cura para essas
associações historicamente estaria
associado a tentativas de normalizar
o comportamento autista,
que poderia gerar intervenções
agressivas para essas crianças ou
adolescentes, né, que poderia gerar
traumas e marginalização.
E muitos pais e de autistas e próprios
autistas de grau de cuidado leve prefere
que os recursos poderiam ser
direcionados pra inclusão desses
autistas na sociedade, pra
acessibilidade, para apoio, paraa
aceitação social, né? Então tem toda
essa questão aí.
Então hoje tá todo mundo muito cheio de
dedos, né, por essas questões aí do
politicamente correto. Então a
comunidade científica começou a mudar as
palavras, os termos para não
desrespeitar
essas famílias, né?
Porém, se tem um lado negativo, né?
Quando você, entre aspas, normaliza o
autismo, isso pode desestimular
pesquisas sobre mecanismos biológicos do
autismo,
porque essas pessoas sofrem, né, pela
sua neuroatipia. Eu acontece com o meu
filho, por exemplo. E se você priva ele
de um tratamento porque você quer
normalizar isso daí, você não tá
prestando um bom serviço para essa
pessoa, no meu ponto de vista.
Então, essa questão aí da forçar a
normalização do autismo vai atrapalhar
pesquisas futuras,
potenciais intervenções preventivas ou
terapias para sintomas que podem causar
sofrimento para esses autistas, né?
E assim tem muitos graus de autismo e
essa normalização pode prejudicar vários
graus de autismo.
Então é importante a gente analisar o
autista como um todo, respeitar as
características dele, mas temos que
pesquisar disbiose, inflamação,
deficiências nutricionais,
tudo isso é muito importante. Então,
normalizar demais o assunto pode gerar
todos esses problemas que eu acabei de
falar de você negar um tratamento, uma
pesquisa, uma investigação para um
autista.
Então, temos que tentar encontrar um
equilíbrio que hoje cada vez é mais
difícil, porque nós estamos vivendo na
época das das polariz polarizações, né,
das radicalizações, né,
respeitar a identidade, né, da dos
autistas, importante, mas sim manter as
pesquisas para melhorar a qualidade de
vida dele.
Vamos pra próxima pergunta aqui
também sobre o autismo. Mesmo sem cura
pro autismo, é possível melhorar 100%
déficit intelectual que essa doença não,
100% não, né?
Eh, de maneira que o paciente,
não sei o que das habilidades
independentemente da idade que inicia o
tratamento.
Óbvio que quanto mais cedo você intervém
no autismo, melhor vai ser os
resultados, certo?
Então, se você faz intervenções tanto
na nutrição, na terapia aba, terapia
ocupacional, fonadiodiologia,
desinflamar, melhorar o intestino, tudo
isso, você vai ter melhores resultados,
tanto nas habilidades de comunicação e
interação social, quanto nas funções
executivas de regulação emocional,
comportamentos adaptativos, autonomia,
eh controle de ansiedade e distúrbios
também. gastrointestinais
dá para em muitos casos, né, de autismo,
de nível de cuidado um, você tem uma
melhora muito expressiva, tá? Mas não
vai querer dizer que você vai chegar a
100%.
vai continuar tendo algumas
características neurodivergentes. No
caso do meu filho,
no começo, quando ele tinha dois, 3, 4,
5 anos de idade, ele tinha muito
problema de comunicação. Hoje ele fala
mais do que homem da cobra, né, como diz
o outro.
E mas ele continua tendo
as peculiaridades dele e agora na
adolescência ele tá sofrendo muita
ansiedade. A gente tá tendo que lidar
com isso, tanto medicamentoso, né,
usando o canabis e outras estratégias,
quanto com terapia psicológica.
Então, o importante aqui identificar
rápido, atuar rápido para você ter os
melhores resultados. Agora 100% você não
vai chegar nesse número.
Lembrando que meu filho desde cedo tá
corrigindo vitamina D, ômega-3,
vários nutrientes ali, carnitina,
coisema Q10. Isso tudo vai ajudar
bastante o autista
e quanto mais cedo você introduzir,
melhor.
Alguns casos vão se beneficiar com
estimulação transcraniana,
neurofedback.
Então, cada caso é um caso, mas temos
que atuar o mais cedo possível.
Quanto mais tarde você iniciar o
tratamento, geralmente você vai ter
menos resultado, tá?
Eh, você disse que autismo tem várias
causas e que seria várias doenças. No
meu no meu entendimento é isso. Então,
quais seriam as principais causas
conhecidas?
E se a causa for tratada e curada, então
pode haver uma cura?
Já falei nisso em outra live, né? As
curas 100% é em torno de 1 a 10%, tá?
Se o paciente for adulto, por exemplo,
mesmo que ele seja curado, ele vai levar
um tempo até se adaptar. Tratamento para
começar num adulto é complicado, tá?
Você tem que começar isso no início da
da infância, né?
Falando em causas aqui, a genética,
apesar de ser uma genética muito
complexa, é a principal causa.
Outra causa seria intoxicação ambiental,
outra causa seria disbiose intestinal,
outra causa seria
uso de alguns medicamentos na gestação,
por exemplo, ácido valpróico, exposição
radiação na gestação,
baixo peso ao nascer também é uma causa,
deficiência de nutrientes durante a
gestação, como vitamina D, ácido fólico,
seria uma causa.
vacinas, assunto extremamente polêmico,
mas existem evidências de que algumas
podem ser aumentar o risco, né?
Então, seria basicamente isso as causas,
tá?
A lepra foi uma doença terrível e
amplamente citada na Bíblia. Já
descobriram a cura há muito tempo, tá?
Porque o nome que a gente dá para isso
hoje em dia é rancenize, tá? O nome
lepra só em termos assim históricos, não
se chama mais de lepra. Então haneniz já
tem mais de 50 anos que tem cura, tá?
E geralmente o tratamento é feito com
combinações de antibióticos.
A maioria deles são antibióticos
da classe da,
me fugiu o nome agora, mas é da
rifampina, colofamimina
e o tempo é bem prolongado porque é uma
bactéria igual da tuberculose, então o
tempo de duplicação é bem lento. Então
quando a bactéria demora para duplicar,
geralmente o tempo de tratamento é bem
longo, é de 6 a 12 meses, igual a
tuberculose, tá?
Então, eh, tem essa questão de ser um
tratamento longo com múltiplos
antibióticos.
E esse tratamento, apesar de ser
prolongado, é eficaz para eliminar a
bactéria.
Porém, se houver já danos nervosos, né,
principalmente nos neurônios sensitivos,
ela, o tratamento não vai reverter esses
danos. Então, é muito importante
tratamento precoce, diagnóstico rápido.
A boa notícia é que cerca de 90% da
população tem uma imunidade natural
contra a doença.
E você pega essa doença através de
contato prolongado com gotículas
respiratórias de pessoas infectadas que
não estão em tratamento.
A vacina BCG, que é uma vacina muito
comum, utilizada há muitos anos,
oferece alguma proteção contra a
ranceníase, apesar de ser uma vacina
contra a tuberculose, ela ajuda um pouco
porque a bactéria da rancenese é
parecida com a bactéria da tuberculose.
E não há uma vacina específica para
rancene.
Como eu falei, a BCG da tuberculose
oferece uma proteção parcial.
Porém, a Fiocruz, né, a Fundação Osvaldo
Cruz iniciou testes clínicos no Brasil
de uma vacina chamada Lepvax.
É uma candidata à vacina de Hancinese,
que já tem segurança demonstrada e pode
aumentar a resposta imunológica estudos
iniciais. Porém, isso tá ainda
em análise. O estudo brasileiro tá na
fase 1B, então tá bem no início, tem 54
voluntários, está avaliando a segurança
e a imunogenicidade no contexto
epidemiológico nosso aqui do Brasil. E
se os resultados forem positivos, a
pesquisa vai avançar para fases que vão
testar a eficácia da vacina em pessoas
infectadas.
OK? Então, tem tratamento há muito
tempo, só não é muito divulgado
e é um tratamento longo aí de 6 a 12
meses.
Em conversa com meu pai, ele falou que a
carne de bode é mais saudável do que de
gado e de ovelha, pois é menos remosa.
Isso procede. Eu acho que rebo está
querendo dizer gorduroso, né?
O leite cabre mais saudável? Sim, de
modo geral, ele é. Mesmo a vaca sendo
criada em pasta orgânico, o leite dela
ainda é problemático? Não. Eh, depende
se for uma vaca bem cuidada, que não
toma muito antibiótico nem hormônio do
crescimento bovino,
pode ser aceitável sim, especialmente se
for caseina dois. Existe uma diferença
entre o leite de vaca brasileiro
europeia americana. Não tem tanta
diferença, porque a vaca do Brasil, na
verdade, são misturas de raças europeias
e asiáticas, né? América a mesma coisa.
A vaca não é um animal natural do
Brasil, é natural da Ásia e da Europa,
né?
Sendo que uma é mais saudável que a
outra
americana não tem. Como eu falei, não é
do continente americano a vaca, né?
Vi o Dr. La Ribeiro falando que a vaca
europeia tem genes diferentes. Cada
espécie de vaca tem genes diferentes,
tá? Então vamos lá. Tem um monte de
coisa que você misturou aqui. Vamos
falar da carne de bode. Aqui
ela é considerada mais saudável sim do
que de gado, de ovelha, porque os dados
nutricionais são melhores. A carne de
bode é mais magra, né? Então pra
medicina convencional isso é uma
vantagem, né? porque teria menos gordura
total, menos gordura saturada. Isso é
discutível, né? Mas isso
é considerado nessa avaliação de que ela
seria mais saudável,
ela também seria mais rica em ferro,
teria mais proteína de alta qualidade.
Então, por causa dessa proteína de alta
qualidade,
ela seria recomendada também.
Então esse termo remoso eu entendo como
gorduroso,
porém isso pode variar dependendo de
quem tá falando isso, né?
Porém, a gente não pode considerar esse
termo remoso na literatura médica, né?
Mas ela é menos gordurosa, como já
falei.
E o leite cabra, ela é
um leite que tem mais vantagens
nutricionais,
tem menos te de lactose,
tem uma digestão melhor da gordura,
apesar de ser mais gorduroso,
tem um potencial alergênico menor, tem
mais minerais como cálcio, magnésio,
potássio, fósforo e vitamina A.
E tem mais ácidos grass de cadeia média,
né, que são interessantes pela
metabolização rápida e para ajudar no
cérebro e na energia.
E tem estudos que sugerem que o leite
cro poderia auxiliar na recuperação de
anemia ferropriva, que é aquela anemia
com deficiência de ferro e na saúde do
osso.
Então porque tem mais biodisponibilidade
em minerais.
Então, de modo geral, sim, o leite de
cabra é melhor.
Em termos de alguns nutrientes, como é o
caso do ácido fólico, vitamina B12,
o leite de vaca tem mais, tá? Mais ácido
fólico, mais B12.
Então, em questão que você falou do
leite de vaca
mesmo de pasto orgânico, prefira o
casina A2, tá?
Tem uma coisa interessante aqui. Existe
raçasicasbuínas
como a Gir e Girolando, que é mais comum
no Brasil que nos Estados Unidos, tem
mais o leite com a casina do, tá?
Isso é um dado importante.
E as espécies que tem no Brasil de de
vaca, que são misturas aí de raças
asiáticas, teriam menos lactose também.
Próxima pergunta.
Mulher tem diabetes, ela não trata, não
faz dieta, não tem dinheiro sempre para
comprar beberina.
Ele diz que sente bem quais os perigos.
Qual dose recomendada de metiformina e
quais horários? A dose de metiformina
varia se o açúcar tiver muito alto, 200
ou 300? A dose pode ser a mesma? Não, a
dose vai ser maior conforme a
necessidade de baixar mais o açúcar, né?
É possível tomar o remédio sem fazer
dieta? Não recomendo. Seria meio
estúpido fazer isso até pelo custo.
Na sua opinião, é extremamente perigoso.
Se você tem diabetes não tratado, é
perigoso sim.
Quais são os riscos, né? Além
obviamente você ter um pé diabético, de
você ter uma cegueira diabética, por
exemplo, infarto, AVC, né? aumento de
risco de câncer, de neuropatia,
insufícia renal.
A dose da metiformina, perdão, é da
metformina é de 500 a 1500 mg por dia,
tá? A bebelina é a mesma coisa.
Tem casos que a gente pode aumentar até
para 2550 mg por dia de metiformina, mas
geralmente dá muita intolerância
intestinal de diarreia e gases. Então,
uma dose mais padrão entre 500 e 1500 mg
por dia,
mas existe casos que pode chegar até
2550 de metiformina,
nunca substituindo as mudanças
alimentares.
Então não faça uso do medicamento sem
fazer dieta. Isso aí seria uma
estupidez, tá? Mas tem gente que não
quer aceitar e vai meter
os equívocos, né? Tenho 36 anos, minha
testosterona livre tá 351 picomoles por
litro e a total 23 nanomes por litro.
Meu médico receitou suplemento super
mira forte da Life Extension. Na sua
opinião, estariam esses valores um pouco
baixo?
Bem, o valor que você colocou aqui, 23,1
mimoles nanomoles por litro
daria aproximadamente 665 n desse litro.
É um valor adequado, tá? Acima do meio
para cima.
Hum.
Agora a textos livre que estaria na
metade inferior da faixa de referência,
apesar da total tá na metade superior.
que aí seria o caso de aumentar um
pouquinho a sua testona livre.
Esse suplemente está falando aí é a base
extrato de Mirabiles Jalapa
que é o super mira forte.
O que eu te diria aí no caso e tentar
aumentar um pouquinho mais essa
testosterona, tá? Talvez com uma dose
baixa de plomifeno, uns 5 mg por dia de
clomifeno,
eu acho que seria uma boa.
Lógico, fazendo musculação, isso é muito
importante.
O CBD tem uma dosagem dose padrão, como
que funciona? É muito, muito variável,
tá? Muito, muito variável. Não existe
uma dose única padronizada para todo
mundo.
Vai depender de uma da sensibilidade
individual, do peso, do sexo, do
metabolismo, um monte de coisa. Então a
dose pode variar tremendamente entre 20
mg até 1500 mg por dia, tá? Olha, olha a
diferença aí, né? Muito grande, né? Para
quase 100 vezes de de diferença.
Então tem que ir tatiando. É assim que
funciona o canabol. Você vai começando
uma dose baixa e vai tatiando.
Então funciona assim. Você começa com
umas 6 mg de carabidol por cada 5 kg de
peso e vai subindo a a dosagem conforme
a necessidade.
E ele é muito útil sim para modular o
estresse.
Tem ação antestress ansiolítica, ajuda
no sono. É um ótimo tratamento para
enxaqueca, para dor crônica,
tá? Então sim, vale muito a pena.
Já falei aqui do Pea, né, na outra
pergunta. Então, Pea, mas o canabidioma
é uma combinação muito boa.
Então, tem que ir subindo aos
pouquinhos, tá? E começar com dose
baixa, 10 a 20 mg por dia e vai subindo
conforme a necessidade.
A pergunta geopolítica aqui, Estados
Unidos e Irã começaram a se atacar.
Parece que a situação já deu uma
acalmada, né? Pelo menos saiu um tweet
aí do Donald Trump falando que ele
conseguiu fazer um acordo de paz aí. Não
sei se é verdade, né? Mas vamos a
pergunta. Se isso for início da terceira
guerra mundial e os preços dos alimentos
subirão muito, imaginando a pior das
hipóteses, talvez tenhamos
uma escassez de alimentos ao ponto de
não conseguirmos nem mesmo comprar
comida. Eu acho que não vai chegar nesse
ponto não, tá? Até que o Brasil é um
grande produtor de comida, né? Supondo
que não tenhamos escolha e sejamos
forçados a escolher apenas dois ou três
alimentos para comer todo dia, esses
dois ou três alimentos seriam carne e
verdura verde escura?
Eu acho que é uma boa escolha, sim.
Se você for priorizar densidade
nutricional e variedade de nutrientes,
carne e verduras verdes escuras seriam
escolhas bem racionais. Mas não vai
chegar nesse ponto não.
A carne realmente é uma fonte completa
de proteínas e micronutrientes.
Para quem não é vegano, né? A proteína
tem todos os aminoácidos essenciais,
tem o ferro M, né, que é a forma mais
biodisponível do ferro.
Tem praticamente todas as vitaminas no
complexo B, especialmente B12. Tem
zinco, fósforo e selênio.
Tem as gorduras também. É, se for um
gado que pastou, vai ter ácidos grásicos
eh necessários pro organismo.
As veduras verde escuras vão ter outras
vitaminas que não vão ter na carne, que
é o caso da vitamina C, da vitamina K,
da vitamina
A, que não é tão forte na na carne
vermelha.
Vai ter também ferro não m magnésio, que
na carne não vai ter tanto. Vai ter o
potássio,
vai ter alguns antioxidantes
betacaroteno, luteína, flavonoides,
vai ter a fibra que não vai ter na
carne, fibra alimentar para alimentar as
bactérias do bem.
Então essa combinação que você falou faz
todo sentido.
Porém, algumas carências poderiam surgir
se você comesse só carne e veduras
verdes escuras.
poderia ter deficiência de energia, né,
dependendo da quantidade de gordura que
você vai ingerir,
pode não ter vitamina C suficiente,
dependendo da quantidade de verdura que
você vai ingerir.
Era, se fosse possível introduzir um
terceiro alimento, introduziria os ovos,
né, que teriam aí graxos que não teriam
na carne, né,
e teria algumas outras vitaminas.
E o sal também, né? O sal que teria o
iodo, né?
Então eu escolheria
verduras e legumes, carnes e ovos, tá? E
também se você conseguir batata doce,
mas isso que tá falando é muito
improvável no meu ponto de vista, tá?
Brasil é produtor de alimento. Mesmo que
fique mais caro, eu acho difícil
chegar a virar uma catástrofe isso aí.
Fiquei sabendo que o termo melatonina
slow release, não é show release, é
slow, né? Se refere ao suplemento
melatonina de liberação lenta. Parece
que a única marca que possui melatonina
de liberação lenta e rápido ao mesmo
tempo é essential, não é? Tem aí outras
marcas no mercado. Segundo eles, no
mesmo comprimido sublingual, a
melatonina é de liberação rápida e
também de liberação lenta. Não tem um
chamado melotime, que também tem a mesma
característica.
Uma farmácia de manipulação também
consegue fazer as duas coisas ao mesmo
tempo. Consegue porque tem esse ativo
chamado melotime, tá?
uma mistura de melaton de liberação
rápida e lenta,
que inclusive eu prescrevo bastante.
O produto da Essential chama Melatonina
Duo, né? Mas não é o único produto que
tem no mercado não.
Vamos para próxima pergunta.
Na live que você fez há mais de um ano
com a Elizete Cfre, ela disse que tinha
alergia de pele, alergias respiratórias,
convulsões, tiroidite, lupos, diabetes,
doença mista no colágeno. Ela afirmou
que durante o período que ficou morando
em Campos de Jordão, não manifestou
nenhuma dessas doenças em nenhum
momento. Suspeitei que fosse por causa
do aterramento.
Encontrei um vídeo onde ela disse que
foi por causa da mudança epigenética.
Morava em São Paulo. Antes disso, muita
poluição, carga tóxica, qualidade de
água.
Essa solução da mudança epigenética do
lugar que funcionou para ela também
funcionaria para pessoas com outras
doenças? Sim, sem dúvida. Isso é bem
comum. Isso aí é desde o século XIX que
as pessoas se mudam de cidade para
tratamento de saúde, né? É modulação
epigenética, né? Porque o ambiente vai
modificar a expressão genética.
Tem vários estudos que mostram que
fatores ambientais, como poluição
atmosférica, qualidade da água,
exposição à toxina de estilo de vida no
interior, que tem menos estresse e mais
contato com a natureza, podem modular o
risco e a expressão de doenças
autoimunes.
Exposição prolongada a poluição do ar
está associada a maior risco de doenças
autoimunes, como lupo, satite,
rematoide,
doenças do tecido conjuntivo, tiroideoto
e outras doenças inflamatórias
intestinais como o crom. E a redução da
exposição a poluentes e toxinas
ambientais pode diminuir inflamação
sistêmica e modular resposta imune.
Tá? Então é fato que fatores ambientais
aí de toxicidade vão aumentar a
expressão de doenças autoimunes como
lupus, esclerose múltipla, doença de
crom
e o grounding ajuda também, tá? Mas no
caso dela, acho que não foi isso não.
O ground, como eu falei em vídeos
anteriores, ele pode ser um codivante
para reduzir a inflamação crônica e
melhorar sintomas,
modulando o sistema inflamatório,
mas não vai substituir, né, outros
estilos de vidas aí importantes, né?
Vamos pra próxima pergunta.
Alimentos de edifício digestão, como a
carne vermelha, por exemplo, não são
indicados para quem tem candidase, porém
mesmo tendo candidase, a pessoa pode
comer carne vermelha todo dia se for
acompanhado do suplemento betaína.
Sim, a betaína vai melhorar a digestão
da carne, né?
Pessoas que têm dificuldade de gerir a
carne vermelha vão ter mais distensão
abdominal porque os nutrientes da carne
vão ser menos digeridos e vão sobrar
para as bactérias comerem, tá? E essas
bactérias produzem gases.
Então, eh faz todo sentido usar o a
cloridade betaína para ajudar na
digestão.
Como é que vai ajudar isso aí? E a
cordade betaína, aumentando a acidez,
vai ajudar a converter o pepsinogênio em
pepsina, que é uma enzima digestiva que
vai quebrar as proteínas em peptidos
menores e facilitar digestão e absorção
de nutrientes.
E além disso, a acidez do estômago vai
ajudar a controlar a proliferação do
Cândida, né, da do fungo Cândida.
Algumas pessoas se consumirem carne
vermelha em excesso vão ter mais
propensão à inflamação e a persistência
do fungo. Apesar que o fungo é muito
mais relacionado a carboidrato que a
carne em si, tá?
Eu
recomendo comer carne vermelha duas a
três vezes por semana, mas o mais
importante para controlar a cândida
seria cortar carboidrato, farinha,
açúcar. OK?
Na live do dia 15 de abril disse: "Teve
um estudo publicado 24 por uma série de
casos em que relatou remissão completa
de depressão e ansiedade em pacientes
após de 7 a 12 semanas de terapia
metabólica cetogênica rigorosa."
Tiveram também a melhora paralela de
parâmetros como sono, energia e função
cognitiva.
Lembro de ter visto um vídeo do Lai
Ribeiro onde ele mostrou a foto de um
sujeito completamente musculoso que
adotava dieta cogênica há 35 anos. Você
conhece alguém que tendo a doença
depressão decidiu se manter na
cetogênica a vida toda para nunca mais
ter depressão na vida? É muito difícil
fazer cetogênica a vida inteira, viu?
E esse pessoal que faz fisiculturismo e
fala que faz cetogênica,
é mais ou menos, não é bem cetogênica,
eles faz é low carb porque eles
concentram o carboidrato no momento do
treino.
Como o metabolismo as pessoas é mais
acelerado por causa da musculação, acaba
que ele fica a maior parte do tempo em
cetose, mas ainda precisa ter essa carga
de carboidrato para aumentar a massa
muscular. Então não é exatamente
cetogênico, tá?
Eles falam que é, mas é parcialmente
cetogênico, podemos dizer assim.
Tem um estúdio 2024 que relatou remissão
completa da depressão e ansiedade em
pacientes após 7 a 12 semanas de terapia
metabólica cetogênica rigorosa. O
problema é manter isso muito tempo, né?
Além da melhora dos sintomas
psiquiátricos, houve benefícios
paralelos de sono, energia e função
cognitiva. Por isso que a gente propõe
essa dieta para quem tem Alzheimer, né?
Então, esse estudo foi apresentado com
uma série de casos no jornal de
psiquiatria metabólica, reforçando o
potencial da gesta cetogênica como
intervenção metabólica para transtorno
de humor.
O problema é a adesão prolongada, né?
Vai ser bem difícil isso.
Teve um caso aí que relatado em
comunidade de medicina funcional do
indivíduo que conseguiu manter a dieta
cetogênica por 35 anos e controlou a
depressão dessa forma.
Bem, se a pessoa conseguir manter a
dieta é ótimo. O problema é realmente
manter por décadas, a maioria das
pessoas não conseguem fazer isso, acaba
indo para low carb,
tá?
Precisamos de mais estudos desse
assunto.
Se eu entendi direito o que você disse
numa live feita há muito tempo,
recomendo-se consumir 1 g a 1,5 g de
proteína por kilo dia, se não estiver
fazendo atividade física. Na dieta
cetogênica, a pessoa tem que consumir
essa mesma quantidade de proteína?
Depende, tá?
Geralmente, se você comer 2 g de
proteína por kilo dia, você não vai
estar na faixa cetogênica
para ter hipertrofia, né? Como eu falei,
você vai precisar de carboidrato, vai
precisar de proteína e a glicose ela vai
ter que subir um pouco para acontecer
isso, né? Então você não vai ficar na
faixa titogênica na maior parte do
tempo.
Para você ter cetose, corpos cetônicos
do sangue, tem que a glicose tem que
baixar
e para ela baixar tanto assim acaba
prejudicando a hipertrofia muscular, tá?
Nós sabemos que quando você come
bastante proteína, parte dessa proteína
quando é convertida aminoácidos, esses
aminoácidos vão virar a glicose através
da gliconeogênese.
Exemplo: Por exemplo, um adulto de 70
kg, o consumo diário de proteína ficaria
entre 84 g e 140 g. Quer dizer, ser
entre 1,2 e 2,
g por dia, por kilo dia, né? Então,
entre 84 e 140 g por dia.
E dividir a proteína ao longo do dia
seria melhor, né, para ajudar na
saciedade e na cise proteica.
as fontes carnes, ovos, peixes,
laticínios, suplementos como o protein
ou pós-proteicos vegetais.
Próxima pergunta e a última.
Qual a sua opinião sobre o none,
benefícios e efeitos colaterais? Eu fiz
um vídeo sobre isso há 6 anos atrás.
Não sei se você assistiu esse vídeo, mas
só mas tá lá, você consegue achar. Eu
achei inclusive esse vídeo hoje,
reassistir ele.
Problema é que a Anvisa proibiu essa
fruta baseada em alguns estudos aí
mostrando toxicidade se você consumisse
em excesso.
Porém, nós sabemos que a none é rica em
vitaminas do complexo B, vitamina C,
minerais e compostos antioxidantes.
Tem ação antioxidante,
ajuda no sistema imune, porém tem uma
toxina também nesse none aí, né? Tem
relatos documentados, mas aí são
relatos. Pessoas que comeram muito
anone, que tiveram lesão hepática,
especialmente quando consumiram o suco
ou extrato concentrado.
Então, acho que 99% das vezes a none não
vai causar problemas, a não ser que a
pessoa realmente consuma uma quantidade
exagerada.
Então você pode gerir com tanto que você
não exceda a quantidade, tá? E assista
meu vídeo sobre esse assunto lá no
canal.
Bem, pessoal, ã, vamos ver se tem
perguntas ao vivo. Dr. Ana Paula entrou
na live, eu nem tinha visto.
Na live de abril, você comentou em fazer
uma live
com um convidado, alguém que sugeriu aí,
mas eu nem cheguei a falar com Alexandre
Costa, não,
eu esqueci de falar com ele também. Não
tenho contato dele, eu acho. Acho que me
passaram o contato dele, sim. Olá, Alice
VGA direto de Portugal. Obrigado por tá
acompanhando a nossa live.
O horário é 10 minutos antes da
refeição, tá?
Sim. É melhor você procurar um notólogo
com formação em medicina do esporte.
Bem, pessoal, já temos uma hora de live,
eu vou encerrar por aqui, tá? Até a
semana que vem. Obrigado pela sua
audiência. Vamos nos falando.